*some clapping*
And with that, I just have two more words to say
OBAMA OUT
*epic mic drop*
*epic theme song
Stand Master: "I will build a great great wall."
Stand Master: "On our southern border and I will have Mexico pay for that wall."
OH MY GOD!!!!!
Chillary Clinton: "I don't know who created Pokemon Go."  (shakes head furiously)
Some dude: "Hillary trying to appeal to young voters
"Is a little bit like you relatively just signed up for baseball."
Chillary Clinton: "I try to figure out how we get them to have Pokemon GO TO THE POLL."
*maniacal laughter*
Some grill: "I don't know why that's funny."
Stand Master: "Uh..I have been against..uh..Japan."
Some dude: "But the fact of the matter is that most of them are childish single men who masturbate to anime."
anime
grab her by the pussy
Stand Master: "What do I know? I mean haven't seen Evangelion." (Trump exe. has stopped working)
News dood: "FBI agents investigated her use of a private email server."
*you got mail and other shit*
News guy: "Bernie Sanders AKA best girl refusal to drop out the presidential race."
Other news dude: "The editorial push back against Bernie Sanders, the calls for him to drop out."
*static*
R.I.P BEST GIRL ;-;-;-;-;-;-;
Best Girl: "We'll make it as clear as possible as to why I'm endorsing Chillary Clinton."
WE'LL MAKE IT HAPPEN
WE'LL TURN IT AROUND
YES WE WERE BORN TO MAKE HISTORY
Stand Master: "Make America *sniff* again."
HAAAAAAAAAAAAA
UUUUUHHAHAHAAHHAA
*EPIC SONG AND SCREAMING*